[Music]
what's going on guys today we're doing a
deep dive into the world of The Witcher
it's the new show coming to Netflix on
December 20th based on the popular
series of books we're gonna talk to the
cast we're gonna talk to the fans we're
gonna do a bunch of cool winter stuff
that they have set up so uh let's get
witchy with it
[Music]
what is a Witcher our preservation
against the darkness it encroaches an
every given moment monster slayer
what's a Witcher I guess like a monster
hunter and I wasn't sure if you were
gonna get that what do you take me for
how someone who hasn't read the books I
take what's a Witcher ha ha
what's the widget a Witcher is in short
a super soldier with no political
affiliation designed to kill monsters so
it's not a witch
are there any actual witches in the show
sorceress is okay what's your - a
sorceress and a witch which is average
day in the life of a Witcher mostly
having people hate you we don't want
your kind here living in the woods maybe
the odd drink if you're lucky okay
trying to find a monster and then
killing it and then hoping you get paid
afterwards it must have been fun working
with Henry Cavill did you guys hang out
off of the set I'm gonna need you to
sign this release form why should I
watch The Witcher instead of making a
murderer have you played the video games
I haven't played the making a murder
video game I didn't even know why you
could be like like Brendan Dassey and be
like my uncle did it
let me out let me out of jail my uncle
did it
you've steal a lot of potions that you
have to drink during the show what what
do they do and what a potions tastes
like what a person's taste like there's
a variety of different things they gave
me I think ultimately it was like a cold
brew coffee was it anything like I drank
a potion of Burning Man once and I saw
spiders everywhere and I fought a ghost
normally hit normally it happens in a
different order it is I see spiders
drink a potion and end up fighting a
ghost
oh that's the Witcher potion yes it's
ever so slightly different similar
effects
how do you spell your name house H al
alright so give me a place of location
house a place and location my mom's
house article of clothing footy pajamas
Billy Paterson ninja throwing stars my
dog Millie okay The Bard is gonna sing
my very own song who you yes anything
for you oh thank you sir mom's house for
where he came three pajamas is what he
wore Billy R is Madison was his mother's
name kiddie monsters was his aim legend
was his thirst for blood ninja star he
used to maim
he rode the town atop his steed Millie
he cried and he would speak a book of
fog monster waited in the moor and soon
its road would be poopface is what they
called the beast though which emerged
from west to east when the two came face
to face poop faces innards were released
and when the plant was filled the rider
took two quills to write the tale of Hal
inhale though which a monster killer
huzzah
thank you good sir ah fine tuned for
thine ear it's tough to say what the
show is about because we are following
three characters throughout the show
from the very beginning the themes of
this show would be xenophobia
colonialism politics love family and
destiny whoa you just got deep dude
there's so much source material for just
the season one how hard was it narrowing
it down and figuring out what the story
that you're gonna concentrate on really
hard Oh baby's challenging there's about
3,000 pages um a books was there
anything that you just had to cut you're
going oh I wish I could have so much um
it is why I'm so grateful that we get
two houses
what's a day in the life of your
characters like manipulating someone
getting angry right running screaming uh
running I've heard tales of your kind
which
the bites look super awesome are you
guys really fighting each other yeah I
mean not really if I don't like trying
to kill each other that's wait I'm gonna
take your first answer yes you're really
fighting each other yeah I told a lot of
people in them oh I think people are
gonna want to see the show that much
more still looking for me in Hungary all
right welcome to America's favorite game
show which sword would you use as you
know if a Witcher was going to kill a
human he would use his steel sword if he
was going to kill a monster he would use
his silver sword I'm gonna name a
creature and you will tell me whether or
not you would kill them with your steel
sword or your silver sword so if you're
gonna kill me what would you use why
would you kill me
steel or silver sword which which one
would use if you were going to kill
Freddy Krueger Oh silver for sure very
good Pennywise the clown I would use
silver and you would be correct
snuffleupagus silver incorrect it's just
a guy in a suit a xenomorph yeah just to
be sure just to be sure just double tap
always double
Ghostface Killah
No Ghostface Killah is a human being
he's a member of the wu-tang clan Method
Man
steel correct he is a man also a member
of the wu-tang clan no I don't think so
the RZA a gremlin silver corrects gizmo
the gremlin steel no gizmo the gremlin
is not a person he's a little monster
also why would you kill gizmo the
gremlin that would be like killing baby
Yoda would you want to kill baby Yoda no
Casper the Friendly Ghost silver no not
steal seal no no silver Casper the
Friendly Ghost
Leatherface whether face
Leatherface yes what about a monstrous
weather man called whether face yeah cuz
I said he was a month yeah Andre you've
officially earned which are status yes
all right
champion I'm a black which I'm a Blitzer
yeah season two Blitzer coming action
you know wise man once said evil is evil
lesser greater middling it's all the
same I want to thank everybody from
Netflix and I want you to check out the
witcher on netflix starting december
20th thanks for watching i'm how london
hit me up on twitter
[Music]